بالنسبة للقلة المحظوظة ، تنتظرهم بعض أفضل ملاعب الجولف
في آسيا
، وأنا ذاهبة لألعب أحد هذه الدورات على بعد
حوالي ساعة من سيول
في شينشون ، مرحبًا بكم في
نادي صافير روك كونتري الذي افتتح في عام
2011 ،
صمم المهندس المعماري تيد روبنسون جونيور
ثلاثة
تسعة حفر  المسارات المذهلة ببساطة
كما يمكنك أن ترى ملعب الجولف هذا قد
تم نقشه من الجبال
ولكن هذا نموذجي جدًا للجولف في
كوريا الجنوبية لأن
هناك نقصًا خطيرًا في المساحة ، لذلك
يحتاج المطورون والمهندسون المعماريون حقًا إلى أن يكونوا مبدعين ولكن في
جوهر
هذا  هو المكان الذي تعيش فيه لعبة الجولف في هذا الجزء
من العالم
في التلال ، أنا ذاهب لألعب بضع ثقوب
مع
مي أوه ، لاعب جولة klpga السابق
والآن نائب الرئيس في صفير روك
واحدة من النساء القلائل الذين وصلوا إلى هذا
المستوى
في كوريا  صناعة الجولف
، قد تحتاج إلى إعطائي بعض اللقطات
الآن أعرف أنني في آسيا بينما يقوم العالم الغربي
بعمل أكواخ في منتصف الطريق
لتناول وجبة خفيفة
في منتصف الجولة في كوريا ، إنه بيت شاي
لهم
[موسيقى]
مع دورة مبهرة مثل هذه  أنت
ني  Ed a 7500
m2 clubhouse لتتناسب مع
هذه العظمة التي
يتوقعها لاعب الجولف الكوري الثري ،
فهذه النوادي ليست مجرد أماكن
تعرفها ، اذهب واشتر كرات الجولف الخاصة بك واحصل على
قفازاتك وأعني أن هناك أماكن
للترفيه غرف خلع الملابس
أماكن الساونا التي تجلب فيها رجال الأعمال ،
لذلك يجب أن يكون هناك
مساحة
كبيرة جدًا
لاستيعاب ما يمثله يوم الجولف في كوريا ،
وأعتقد أنه من المقبول أن نقول إن هذه كوريا
تُعرف نوعًا
ما بالثقافة الباليبالية.  سريعًا جدًا عندما جاء
أعضاء فريق من العالم الغربي
مثلي ،
أردنا إبطاء الأمور
قليلاً والتركيز
على الجودة ، وقد التقينا في المنتصف
بهاتين
الفلسفتين ، وهو
دليل على أن
ثقافتين مختلفتين يمكن أن يجتمعا
و  حقًا ابتكر شيئًا
جيدًا الآن إنه ببساطة لكن الكوريين يحبون
ملاعب الجولف عالية جدًا في الوقت
الحالي
إنها تجربة فريدة من نوعها بشكل لا يصدق
لأي شخص آخر  مكان في العالم ،
قد لا تتناسب الرحلة إلى كوريا الجنوبية
مع ميزانية الجميع ، ولكن مع دورات مثل
صفير
سياحة الجولف الصخري في هذا البلد ، من المؤكد أن
ترتفع